When I was named president
of Harvard, there was a lot
of attention paid to the fact
that I am the first
woman president
and there was a press
conference the afternoon
that my appointment was
announced and I just
about the first question that
I got from a reporter referred
to me as the woman president
of Harvard and I reacted
to that almost with that.
I hadn't thought it through
in advance how I'd react,
but it just came out.
I said, I'm not the
woman president of Hart.
I'm the president of Harvard,
and by that I think I wanted
to underscore that I didn't want
to be in a separate category.
I didn't want to be
thought of as less
than all the other presidents
of Harvard, but I learned a lot
in the very first weeks
after making that comment.
I still would stand
by that comment,
but I'd understand it
more broadly in that.
During those weeks, I got
dozens and dozens of letters
and communications from people
all over the world and people
who wrote to me included a
lot of young women and a lot
of parents have sometimes
very young women like babies
who just been born and
the message that came
through in this series of
letters and other kinds
of messages was how
important it was to them
that there was a woman
president of Harvard and how
that enabled them to expand
what they could imagine
for themselves.
And so I thought I need
to occupy this status
as woman president of Harvard
and use the platform and try
to be the role model that all
these correspondence had asked
me to be.
So that is something that
I very much kept in mind
as I've been president over
the last 11 years and met
with young women and girls
schools all over the world
and in the United States.
And tried to fill
that expectation
of what a woman president
of Harvard could mean.